okay let's go to your voicemail we have
a voicemail number that number is two
one nine two David P the phone number is
being blocked by this balloon let's see
if I can there we go just out of the way
let's take a listen to this voicemail
that came in hi David I just wanted to
read Isaiah 312 and down a couple down
that fifteen real quick childish leaders
oppressed my people and women rule over
them oh my people your leaders mislead
you they send you down the wrong road
Lord this goes on for three minutes
why are you reading biblical verses to
me i what has ever happened on this
program Pat that would lead someone to
call in and say here's an idea
I'm gonna read three minutes of the
Bible to someone uh and that's going to
get me to do what I like I just don't
even understand what I'm supposed to do
with that maybe he thought you didn't
have a Bible at home which is true yeah
or access to one and by the way this is
actually pretty common there are lots of
people who call sometimes multiple times
in a row and just cite scripture to me
and I never even end up knowing like
what story are you reacting to I just
have no idea it's just scripture of
absolutely no no meaning or valued but
you can save all these voicemails put
them together and then you have an audio
book of the Bible yes and then we could
sell it on Amazon or something like that
that's how we could turn the Bible verse
voicemails into something anyway call in
to 192 david p but don't read bible
verses all right but there's there's
better things to do with the voicemail
time on the bonus show today a judge has
ruled that donald trump gets his way
when it comes to the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau we have a growing HIV
epidemic in Europe not where many of us
might think it is a growing epidemic and
also Mike Pence says that Donald Trump
is again actively considering moving the
American Embassy in Israel from Tel Aviv
to Jerusalem I've said it before this
would be a disaster and it would be a
disaster that is on today's bonus show
get access by being a member or by
making a contribution on patreon of at
least five bucks a month